imaginez un baromètre graduée de 1 à 10
où il plaçait vous votre sensibilité
etes-vous souvent arrêtés par la beauté
d'un paysage ou d'une musique à tel
point que les larmes aux yeux vous monte
tellement c'est magnifique
et vous la personne qui sont les odeurs
que personne ne sont
vos émotions agréable comme désagréable
sont elles plutôt intense
avez vous l'impression de deviner
rapidement l'humeur de votre
interlocuteur
alors peut être faites vous partie des
25 à 30% de la population qu'on dit
hypersensible un hyper sensible au sens
d'une sensibilité élevée plus élevées
que celles de la plupart des gens
si nous sommes environ au sens et si ce
soir 29 d'entre vous plus moi même
partageons cette caractéristique
invisible qui fait que nos sensations
sont nombreuses et à la fois plus subtil
plus intense et que notre réactivité
émotionnelle est plus forte
en quoi notre cerveau est il différent
des autres
est ce que ces caractéristiques ne
confère une intelligence émotionnelle
plus élevés et comment vivre sereinement
avec
alors après dix ans de recherche en
neurosciences c'est généralement vers ce
domaine que je me tourne pour trouver
des réponses objectives donc je vous
propose de prendre ces questions les
unes après les autres pour voir ce que
la science nous dit et si si c'est tout
à fait possible d'avoir une sensibilité
élevée et b rationnelle à la fois
à leur première question en quoi le
cerveau d'une personne à sensibilité
élevée est-il différent du cerveau d'une
personne moins sensible pour pouvoir
répondre à cette question il s'agit
d'abord de s'accorder sur ce qu'on
entend par son sibilité en neurosciences
la sensibilité c'est la capacité à
percevoir des informations sur le monde
à travers nos sens
je sens une odeur j'entends un son je
perçois une couleur je ressens une
douleur qu'il s'agit ici de sensibilité
sensorielle
la sensibilité c'est aussi la capacité à
être touchés modifié à réagir à ce que
l'on perçoit
si j'entends à son jeu peut être
surprise et me retourner si je perçois
un froncement de sourcil sur votre
visage je vais peut-être commencer à
appréhender ce qui va se passer dans ce
cas là il s'agit plutôt d'une
sensibilité émotionnelle qui concerne ma
réaction au monde
une sensibilité élevée serait donc un
ensemble de capacités de comportement
qui concerne à la fois nos sensations et
nos émotions
la sensibilité vous voyez un concept
complexe à l'interface entre sensations
et émotions ce qui fait qu'il est assez
difficile à étudier scientifiquement
du coup nous avons peu de résultats
le premier challenge c'est de déterminer
qui est hyper sensible pour ceux ci nous
avons à disposition seulement un outil
un questionnaire d'auto-évaluation qui
comporte environ une vingtaine
d'affirmations auquel il s'agit de
répondre par oui ou par non pas très
scientifique me direz vous peut-être
cette gent d'outils qui est utilisée
régulièrement dans les études sur la
personnalité et c'est grâce à ce
questionnaire qu'on a pu établir que 25
à 30% la population aurait une
sensibilité donc plus élevée que celle
partagée par la plupart des gens qui
devient du coup une sensibilité plutôt
moyenne dans la norme alors c'est pour
ça que je préfère parler de sensibilité
élevée plutôt que d'hypersensibilité qui
pourrait contenir peut-être une notion
de trop
alors tout ceci étant établis nous
pouvons répondre à cette première
question en quoi le cerveau d'une
personne à sensibilité élevée est-il
différent peu d'études donc peu de faits
mais nous en avons 3 qui semble
significatif le premier
le cerveau des personnes à sensibilité
élevée semble avoir une réactivité plus
importante c'est à dire que les zones du
cerveau qui vous permettent d'être
alerte vigilant de réagir semble
s'activer plus rapidement chez les
personnes à sensibilité élevée
ces structures se situe dans ce qu'on
appelle la formation réticulé au sein du
tronc cérébral et on peut mesurer
l'activité structure en recueillant des
micros courant à la surface de la peau
or à l'écouté d'un sont ces micro
courant apparaissent plus rapidement
chez les personnes les plus sensibles
comme s'ils un système sensoriel avait
besoin finalement de moins de
stimulation pour être activé
ce qui pourrait expliquer que les
personnes à sensibilité élevée cap et
réagissent plus rapidement à des
informations plus subtile donc la
prochaine fois vous sursautez lorsqu'un
collègue vous parle ou que vous trouvez
que votre voisin parle vraiment trop
fort vous saurez pourquoi c'est que
votre cerveau capte et réagi plus
rapidement à des informations plus
subtile
deuxième fait significatif sur les
personnes hypersensibles et leur cerveau
il semble que les aires du cerveau qui
analyse en profondeur les informations
sensorielles émotionnel soit plus dense
et plus active également dans le cerveau
des personnes les plus sensibles par
exemple pour les personnes les plus
sensibles aux sons on s'aperçoit que les
zones du cerveau qui analyse en
profondeur des sont donc au niveau des
lobes temporaux
sont donc plus actives ont plus de
matière grise plus de matières corticale
que dans le cerveau des personnes des
moins sensible on a pu aussi observé
dans deux études que des zones qui
traite des informations émotionnel et
sensorielle sont plus actives dans ça
vaut des personnes plus sensibles lorsqu
on leur montre des images chargé
émotionnellement ou des visages qui
exprime des émotions
on a vu aussi que j'ai des femmes plus
sensibles à l'ecoute de cris d'enfants
leur amie d'anne une structure qui
réagit particulièrement dans les
situations émotionnelles et plus active
donc globalement il semblerait que le
cerveau des personnes plus sensibles
s'activent plus lorsqu'on lui présente
des informations sensorielles et
émotionnel ce qui pourrait expliquer que
ces personnes soient plus réactive et
plus attentive à ces informations dans
leur environnement
donc la prochaine fois vous avez
l'impression de réagir de façon exagérée
à une situation vous savez pourquoi
c'est que votre cerveau lui-même est
plus actif à l'écouté de ces
informations
ça pourrait aussi peut être expliquée
l'intensité que certaines personnes
hypersensibles partage
troisième fait sur le cerveau
hypersensible il semblerait que des
zones qui nous permettent d'être en
empathie soit plus active chez les
personnes les plus sensibles
alors qu'est-ce qui se passerait dans
votre cerveau site où la couche perdais
mes moyens et fondait en larmes
votre cerveau s'activerait en miroir
comme si limitait l'émotion de tristesse
que vous verriez alors apparaître sur
mon visage
c'est neurones qu'on dit neurones
miroirs se situe au niveau de vos lobes
frontaux en particulier dans une zone
qu'on appelle l'insula
et dans les cerveaux les plus sensibles
des personnes les plus sensibles on a pu
observer que lorsqu'on leur présente un
visage qui alertent risso heureux
cette zone là est plus active ce qui
pourrait expliquer que ces personnes
hypersensibles et l'impression de
ressentir facilement et plus fortement
généralement aussi les émotions des
autres
donc la prochaine fois que vous avez
l'impression de ressentir très fortement
la colère de votre interlocuteur ou sa
déception vous serez que c'est sûrement
un coût de votre insu là cela vous
permettra de relativiser et dédramatiser
vous mais bon d'apprendre trois faits
sur le cerveau hypersensible ont tout
d'abord sa réactivité plus importante
les zones qui traite en profondeur les
émotions et des sensations sont plus
actives et les zones qui permette
l'empathie affectifs sont aussi plus
active
la sensibilité élevée semble donc bien
être une réalité
est ce que ces capacités différentes au
niveau des sensations et des émotions
confère à la personne y perd son signe
une intelligence émotionnelle plus élevé
nous arrivons donc vous voyez à notre
deuxième question alors en neurosciences
l'intelligence émotionnelle c'est
l'ensemble des capacités qui nous
permettent de traiter les émotions
et une émotion en neurosciences
affective c'est un signal qui nous
renseigne sur l'état de nos besoins
par besoin j'entends des besoins
physiologiques mais aussi des besoins de
plus haut niveau que tous les humains
partagent des besoins de destine de
relation d'amour de reconnaissance de
d'accomplissement lorsque ces besoins
sont satisfaits
nous ressentons en général des émotions
agréable et lorsque ces besoins sont peu
ou pas satisfaits nous ressentons des
émotions désagréables
une émotion c'est donc un signal à
accueillir à décoder à comprendre pour
l'utiliser ensuite dans nos actions
par exemple si vous réalisez qu en
arrivant au travail vous êtes
généralement contracté tous les matins
en vous interrogeant vous pouvez
comprendre que finalement vous êtes
peut-être en colère et que cette colère
mais du fait que votre besoin de
reconnaissance n'est pas nourri dans ce
travail
d'avoir conscience de cette émotion et
de son message vous pourrez vous
permettre d'agir d'utiliser cette
émotion pour aller peut-être demandé un
rendez vous à votre boss
l'intelligence émotionnelle c'est aussi
la capacité à réguler ses émotions à
faire en sorte qu'elles soient audibles
ni trop faible ni trop forte
en effet si on vous crient dans
l'oreille en général vous n'entendez pas
ce qu'on vous dit
alors est ce que le fait de capter et
ressentir des émotions des autres nous
rend forcément plus intelligent
émotionnellement dans ma pratique
d'accompagnement j'ai pu remarquer que
ce qui va faire la différence c'est la
capacité justement à réguler ses
émotions si on a l'impression d'être
submergé par les émotions des autres ou
envahies par nos propres émotions il va
être plus difficile de décoder ces
signaux de les accueillir et de les
comprendre
alors que faire si on est régulièrement
envahie ou submergés par nos émotions ou
celle des autres
que faire si comme gustave flaubert le
ressentais si on est envahi par une
sensibilité qui nous semble absurde et
qui fait que ceux qui érafle les autres
nous déchire on arrive donc à notre
troisième question comment vivre
sereinement la sensibilité élevée i
la réponse des neurosciences est simple
utiliser votre cortex préfrontal
alors je vous explique lorsqu'on est
dans une situation émotionnelle il ya
plusieurs acteurs qui monte sur la scène
dans votre cerveau donc deux principaux
votre cortex préfrontal est votre amie
d'anne
l'amygdale va réagir d'autant plus
fortement que la situation est
importante pour vous donc plus est
important pour vous plus vous serez
stressé plus vous serez en colère puis
vous serez anxieux et plus votre ami
dalle sera active et plus votre ressenti
subjectif émotionnelle sera intense et
cette réponse de l'amygdale est
complètement automatique elle dépend de
votre analyse inconsciente de la
situation
le cortex préfrontal lui réalise une
analyse plus rationnelle de la situation
et va vous permettre de décider quoi
faire quelle action entreprendre et
cette activité dans le cortex préfrontal
et sous la direction plus contrôlée de
votre conscience
alors c'est là que ça devient
intéressant d'écouter bien lorsque
l'activité dans le cortex préfrontal
augmente l'activité dans l'amygdale
diminue automatiquement
et votre intensité émotionnelle
subjective diminuent également donc
votre cortex préfrontal réguler
l'activité de votre amie d'anne c'est
donc tout à fait possible de réguler de
façon volontaire son intensité
émotionnelle
[Musique]
alors comment faire pour activer son
cortex préfrontal
il ya différentes études et tout monde
qu'un ensemble de techniques assez
simple finalement active effectivement
le cortex préfrontal
il s'agit en général de technique qui
permet de prendre de la distance par
rapport à la situation émotionnelle
en accueillant en émotions en se
distrayant en relativisant en réévaluant
la situation d'une façon plus positive
en se projetant en avant dans des
actions concrètes
prenons quelques instants pour examiner
la première de ces stratégies d'accepter
ce qui nous arrive
qu'est ce qui se passe lorsque vous
faites pas face à une vague
vous vous ready s'est lui tourné le dos
en général va vous frapper de plein
fouet et par surprise
alors que si vous sautiez dedans si vous
plongiez à l'intérieur si vous savez
faire si vous surfez sur la vague
l'expérience sera beaucoup plus agréable
c'est la même chose avec une vague
émotionnelle
l'accepter l'accueillir accepté d'être
éclaboussé il plonger dedans se laisser
submerger permet en général dans de la
vie beaucoup plus facilement d'en faire
baisser l'intensité
maintenant vous savez différents faits
sur votre cerveau hypersensible peut
être aussi que l'intensité de cette
vague de cette prochaine pac sera moins
surprenante et donc plus facilement
acceptable
accepté l'émotion ça permet de
l'accueillir comme un message qui vient
vous dire quelque chose sur vos besoins
et accepter l'émotion ça permet aussi
d'être capable de relativiser beaucoup
plus facilement qui est donc une autre
technique de régulation émotionnelle
avant vous puissiez utiliser toutes ces
techniques et vous entraîner avec je
peux vous proposer simplement la
prochaine fois que vous êtes envahis par
une émotion que vous soyez c'est très
sensible au pas de simplement pensé à
cette boucle régulatrice entre votre
cortex préfrontal et votre ami dame
jeanne d'y penser activera votre cortex
préfrontal et vous aurez déjà un effet
régulateur
alors l'hypersensibilité n'est pas une
pathologie elle peut cependant être
exacerbée dans certains contextes de
troubles tels que l'anxiété ou la
dépression elle peut être aussi
exacerbée dans des contextes dramatique
traumatiques telles que du harcèlement
au travail on est dans ces cas-là il
convient bien sûr d'adresser ses
difficultés au delà de la sensibilité
élevée pour obtenir des résultats de
régulation plus durables et efficaces
alors pour conclure la science nous
montrent que la sensibilité élevée est
une réalité qui va modeler nos
comportements ont même titre que
d'autres caractéristiques l'invisible
tels que nous capacités intellectuelles
notre personnalité notre histoire de vie
il ya de nombreuses personnes qui vivent
très bien leur sensibilité élevée donc
bien régulé et bien un accepter une
sensibilité élevée devient une source un
incroyable d'informations sur le monde
sur les autres sur nous mêmes elle nous
permet d'être plus intelligent des plus
agile plus subtile
alors je terminerai avec ces mots de
baudelaire ne plus mépriser la
sensibilité de personnes la sensibilité
de chacun c'est son génie